welcome to New York there's so much to
do here like taking a walk into a
favorite TV show look it's the street
corner would carry through shoot mr. big
and he is my trainer what we're for no
reason einstein-rosen screw those stupid
jokes
I hate those shows hey I'm coming the
nunzio unemployed actor and real New
York little so I do like law and order
let me take you on the best TV show
walking tour in New York the lord of
dead body walking tours found in every
episode of Law & Order Law & Order SVU a
lawn mower criminal intent location and
with dinner and the breakfast and
another lunch here's a taste of the tour
this is where they found the dead body
in long order episode 108 SVU season 2
episode 8 moose targeted stood right
here right on this exact spot the shoes
like I don't see the dead body where is
it but she turned and she looked right
there and she was like oh there's the
dead body
it's an actual dead body we should
probably keep moving
we will also be doing reenactments
action I don't think he killed them here
just dump them
oh that's left is part of an arm and
some dental remains intimates and
guesswork to put this tour together will
you regret it
find out our reminder nunzio's law not a
dead body to the parts every day and 11
a.m. means one of the spa
what an awful man
you